[Music]
in animal testing news oh no this one
you're not gonna know I thought it was
gonna be teaching dogs math problems
yeah that'd be sweet
okay submitted by love from Germany hi
guten Tigers I don't know any drove
guten tag I understand that one Chinese
scientists are introducing human brain
genes into monkeys cool they're what in
wait we don't like this this is sick
that's how Planet of the Apes hurts them
what are you talk about monkeys this
monkey Oh cuz maybe knowledge is pain no
we're like baby it's not the knowledge
part where it's dirty because we don't
know where we're doing I think they give
them painkillers yeah the monkeys are
feel pretty good about the prize
definitely sedate them or else they're
to be moving and squirming everywhere
yeah exactly
monkeys are strong - monkeys on morphine
they scratch people they'll bite you
they're strong they rape and they tear
apart other monkeys and then when the
way they fight they'll like rip off a
limb
yep I saw a documentary with niggy wear
this monkey tribe like ate one of their
own and they [ __ ] were like walking
around with his hand yeah I was a baby
it was a baby buggy they ripped him
apart and they were all like eating like
parts of his arms instead of just
walking around this [ __ ] hand
flopping around like he's holding the
other monkey's hand monkeys are
herbivores but when they take over
another tribe of monkeys they just like
become they just eat the out of
dominance they like eat the village yeah
nothing can go to waste and I respect
that but they have a sense of humor
though I love I love them I love walls -
they gotta be an overall put them on
clothes in a brief kit with a briefcase
I love it here is George is this money
you'll all have my favorite [ __ ] eating
Ben what a [ __ ] hat on a monkey
I'll probably hit the ground laughing
usually the Chinese scientists have Jean
Hecht a group of monkeys to make them
smarter oh thanks guys
porque why because
they're trying to understand the
development or like the evolution of
human cognition so they're trying to
create it and play God
well I don't know we play John every
Genting yeah yeah so what they did is
this is like some island of dr. Moreau
[ __ ] Nicky no Rosanna [ __ ] movie it's
not a movie it's a book you [ __ ]
idiot yeah but Val Kilmer was in the
movie had bombed famously look at those
eyes and it also had what's-his-name in
from The Godfather I know I saw this
movie and they paid him like a million
dollars to do it and then he like he
wouldn't do any of the lines from the
script isn't [ __ ] was like a name you
know yeah cuz it was a face of famous
bomb well anyway I read the book wasn't
a bomb why would he not you would get
paid to be an actor and he doesn't want
to he would merge different animals you
take like a frog and a cat and like
merge them together like almost like a
human centipede human centipede but with
animals yeah maybe that's what the
Egyptian's did see that's what I'm
saying so that's Jeff says like in spy
kids doesn't say like in Jurassic Park
grannies oh [ __ ] she's just like in
spike it's very much so like that yeah
like a monkey tarantula
I was too cool for spy kid because I was
like 16 I was like Noddy
yeah you're [ __ ] old and everyone's
like this movie was so sick and I was
like I bet it's actually kind of sick
but I might not choose a movie or was it
show the movie up to all four of them or
something I don't even know what that
[ __ ] is damn you guys old what is Spy
Kids movie how about a shy boy and
Lavagirl
yeah I was a Taylor Lautner
oh yeah [ __ ] shark boy my kid she
said like her long ass [ __ ] name oh I
thought Jackie Chan was in spiked kids I
believe it he's in a spy don't he was
called spike I know Stallone was in a
spike in rowdy kids anyway no that's
like what happened with the brains so
they used so they gene edited the human
gene microcephaly which is MC ph1 wow
that was and so they expressed it during
the fetal stage and like they use this
for the monkeys and it turned out the
monkeys that they did this to they were
I wonder how much smarter so what they
did is that they these transgender medic
weight transgender butchers transgenic
transgenic monkeys they had better
short-term memory they they scored like
faster in recognizing colors and all
this other [ __ ] like wooden monkeys do
tests they're just sitting there and
they're like give me my Apple give me my
hat bone huh alright give me my Apple I
love Japan
um with block pictures see Michael
Jackson knew what he was doing they'll
rip your face off wait which which which
context are we talking about get a monk
level bubbles oh yeah Oh balls bad yeah
yeah the zoo this is true Neverland Han
is never that rare wait so what's balls
a chimp yeah you would hold him like a
baby but that was war a lady and a chimp
director faceoff dude I saw a monkey for
sale in Vegas and who's five grand I was
like that's pretty sick was it a
chimpanzee no I was like a little spider
monkey and he was in his cage like I
call that [ __ ] and I was like oh he's so
cute
you did make a word diapers I don't like
spider monkey and those illegal to have
as a pet you know I
I fell yeah perimeter yeah but you threw
the ideas how on a chimp a sphere and
cut a monkey
yeah Marcel mm-hmm I want an elephant
and a chimpanzee
that's all doable you can do that my
tattoo artist had an alligator in the
back I wanna tell you in the tent
alligator it was like [ __ ] this big
like reptiles because I don't know where
you get an elephant Joe that's great
they need to walk a lot yes I love
[ __ ] name in the alligator dude
40-mile oh yeah Timmy or whatever the
[ __ ] and he's just a [ __ ] wild animal
alligator who's your pet that will eat
you when they're hungry
I was just such a depressing video about
this elephant that could paint I know
and like you would paint a picture of an
elephant and I was like wow that's so
[ __ ] around is painting a picture of
an elephant but then I was reading about
how they've trained them to paint
pictures and they beat them yeah like
they beat them until they until they
paint it right and I thought I saw I was
an elephant the like painting and then
like that because don't do that at the
zoo that's Nicky we're all dead the
circus like to train them to create
perfect strokes so they have really good
memory but like to make them repeat the
same strokes all the time they have to
like prod them and beat them and shake
them with hooks and an elephant is like
I'm gonna paint an elephant today person
drawn open and I remembered it and then
it drew an elephant I [ __ ] love leaky
world but that's why I research before I
go oh that's cute I go how they make
this animal do this yeah there's a video
right now of an elephant that's playing
basketball with the guy and he's like
trying to block him and then he dunks
the ball and go you should look up how
they teach
elephants are smart no maybe it's ER
dude if I had an elephant I wouldn't do
none of that
whatchu hide it elephant sneakers why
don't I play with them but then I would
have beat his ass too like I put [ __ ]
sneakers on the elephant and then I
haven't play basketball when Jordan and
paint like a number for their Jersey on
with with animal-friendly paint thank
you
and they separate the babies from moms
Nick you're depressed again Nicky what
the [ __ ] we don't want to know the
knowledge Nicky sad right now you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna find an
orphaned elephant that was abandoned by
the Elephant tribe and I'm gonna I'm
gonna rescue that elevator and then
we'll got lost down that the yeah I got
lost because of poachers or something
yeah I got a guy I I'm gonna yeah and
I'm gonna rescue the elephant and then
grow little Dumbo into big Dumbo okay
we're gonna be he's gonna be my truck I
love it and I want to support it
financially it's a friendship you guys
remember operation Dumbo drop know that
[ __ ] movie yes oh where they have to
get Danny Glover's in this movie I don't
even remember one thing about the
[ __ ] movie other than the [ __ ]
airlifting it's like the Free Willy yeah
I just remember the kid getting out I
remove his daddy says well you should be
hanging out with that [ __ ] whale even
now daddy's Willy he's cool I could love
parents and 90s movies dude you
shouldn't be doing anything fun at all I
know and that's always like God you know
why I hang out with with Willy because
you're never around like all that [ __ ] I
love it it was it's so sad cause it was
so true in a 19-yard both parents
working their [ __ ] asses off latchkey
children nobody [ __ ] home I never saw
my dad
no where are you gonna stay home mom
yeah I didn't so I didn't have any
parents at home I was a latchkey kid why
are there always working yeah they were
both working full-time jobs I'm thinking
and I wasn't a lot to go down ones house
because I thought that I would get lost
or something so I just had to be alone
at home watch TV that's a thing now both
parents working and and it's like just
normal I think both trans be on iPads is
a thing now we're [ __ ] there they're
all together in a row all the children
the families on the iPad talk yeah dude
I mean but in our generation was all of
us watching TV while eating
yeah good think about it like you can't
watch your show then you like you have
to watch whatever give the kids want to
watch I'd rather go to my room and watch
but I want to watch and let them watch
what they want to watch yep I enjoy
watching stuff with Leia though yeah but
[ __ ] all [ __ ] going like this and
[ __ ] dude
no she's running now we watch ahead
opposed to the minions but then dude
when you say you like want to sit with
Leia you just like watching her react
right there no right no but it's not
like you're going like hey Leia would
you think Incredibles - yeah she laughs
- do laughs I wanna watch Umbrella
Academy and they want to watch like the
50th time of Moana I'm like oh I'm like
Moana is officially ban dude at 50 its
banned bro yeah so like they can watch
their show that I watch on my iPad my
show dude hang with my [ __ ] knees in
San Diego I'm like the songs from the
kid shows get stuck in my head yeah on
repeat forever exactly they're built
that way and so I'm like I'm [ __ ]
every time I go down there I'll make my
own movies for my kids then [ __ ] that
watch them yep my way they're gonna
watch your skin baby you're the most
famous person he's like this is a
cartoon about your dad who has a pet
elephant although it's not seem like a
children's show
[Music]